here's a here's a reflection guys um i
think we're all after
inner peace right we all we all want to
empty our minds of the
castigating and oppressive
thoughts that characterize the mental
pathologies of anxiety and depression
these
sort of looping interpretive frameworks
that disempower
us and amputate our will and our sense
of agency in the world we want to
free ourselves from these trappings and
we want to
empty our minds that is what
inner peace is supposed to be all
about but i'd like to offer an
alternative interpretation i think we
make a mistake in describing inner peace
as emptying our
minds you know a lot of these meditation
practices
demonize thought they demonize
all mental content right it's like they
group all mental content which includes
awe
and wonder and curiosity and joy and
beautiful storytelling capacity they
group
that with the pathologies of an
overactive ego that's ruminating and
obsessing over things that can't control
that that nihilism that takes hold of a
mind
in anxiety and depression that's not the
same
thing that's not representative of all
of our mental content but it seems that
these days
the the obsession with meditation has
demonized
all thought people are afflicted with
histrionic
narratives that don't serve them anymore
and they think the only cure is to empty
their vessel
empty your mind find silence find
a vacuum of thought and then you'll find
inner peace but i
just don't buy that story i interpret it
differently see i think inner peace
comes not
from emptying our minds necessarily
but from temporarily dissolving the
narratives that don't
serve us and then constructing from the
ashes
a new personal mythos that does
serve us like all great films
we need plot we need conflict we need
preoccupation
we need agitation we need something that
propels the narrative
forward we need something that compels
us into action
we need we need narrative tension you
know a movie
without preoccupation a movie without
agitation
conflict or plot would be the most
boring movie ever made so when i heal
when i hear this glorification of
meditation as
as emptying your mind completely of all
thought as if all
thought was the great evil i think that
sounds
boring i want not the absence of mental
content
i want instead better mental content
i want to craft autobiographical
narratives that allow
for the trifecta of what jamie wield
describes as extasis catharsis and
communion
right like i want to be propelled into a
great journey
that unfolds with narrative tension that
moves me forward as i resolve
conflict along the way one in which
everyone i meet is a potential teacher
and everything that happens is a
potential lesson and eventually i reach
what jamie wheel calls the blissfuck
crucifixion i have a death and
resurrection like the plot unfolds
beautifully like the greatest movie
you've ever seen i want to be engrossed
i want my life to be full of heightened
qualitative intensity
i want to be engaged in the movie
immersed in the movie entranced in the
movie of my life
but i want it to have a coherent and
wonderful narrative
a narrative of reconciliation
transformation
growth and ultimately like sort of
cathartic and ecstatic understanding
almost like they say
in that movie one day we'll all fall
down and weep and understand it all
all things so i guess ultimately what
i'm saying here is
we must be careful of falling too far
down the rabbit hole of of thinking that
all
thought is bad and that the solution to
our ills is to be empty of thought
you know thought has given us all the
fruits of human imagination and human
consciousness every story every myth
those every spectacular cathedral
every pyramid that was built every
rocket ship that took off
for the moon claude shannon's theory of
information that allows for the wireless
telepathic intermediation of minds
across the world in this
new sphere that has wired the planet all
of these things have come from thought
the most sublime in mathematics the most
awe-inspiring science all of these
things
emerged from armentation from mental
content from
thinking it is not thought that is our
problem it is thinking the wrong kind of
thoughts so ultimately that's what i
want to leave you with is
reframe this whole narrative around
psychopathology and
demonization of thinking it is not
thought that is your problem it is that
you're not
deploying your neocortex in the right
way you're not dreaming the right dreams
you're not thinking the right things
you're not you're not
engendering to design and artfully
create in your world
the plot points that will propel you
forward to make of your life a dynamic
work of art
right because john paul sartre said life
exists in individual moments and it is
up to us to make sure those moments are
vital
and interconnected and grand to cohere a
narrative to make
a masterpiece out of our lives one that
we would willingly live
again and again for all of eternity this
is what we can strive for you know
use your thoughts to ou to author and
usher in a hero's journey for yourself
craft a personal
mythology build your own myth live by
your own myth we are
creatures of mind and meaning we are not
creatures that live with the absence of
thought
we are thought we are creatures of mind
we are creatures of meaning we are
creatures of signification
we are creatures of pattern and we are
creatures of story
so craft a story think your story into
being
write your story into being
emptying your mind fully living without
thought
feels like a cop-out to me instead
courageously courageously move
towards that which you fear the cave
that you fear which holds the treasure
you seek
courageously author with with
with discerning intentional penmanship
create your life create your narrative
create your world
that i think is how we all become
philosopher
kings that i think
is how we move forward so thanks for
listening
and have a beautiful and glorious day